[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL SAXMAN: Hello, and welcome
to this week's episode
of Google Maps Garage.
I'm Paul Saxman.
And with me is Mano Marks.
And this week we're going to
talk about advanced map
markers using the Google
Maps utility library.
So Mano, you're probably a
little more familiar with the
Google Maps utility
library than I am.
Do you want to give
a little review.
MANO MARKS: Sure.
So the Google Maps utility
library started--
well, we actually had
one for Maps API V2.
And we now have migrated a lot
of this functionality to V3.
And basically the idea is
similar to a lot of other
APIs, where they have what are
called plug-ins, we released
utility libraries that work with
the API to add additional
functionality.
And one of the reasons we do it
this way instead of putting
them into the main API is
because we do them in a fairly
specific way.
But we want to allow people
through the open source
library to modify the behaviors
of each of the
individual libraries.
So in these cases, since they
were all open source, you can
then go in and actually pull out
the source and change it
to behaving the way
that you want.
So for instance, I'm going to
talk about marker cluster.
And there are different
clustering algorithms
that one can use.
In this way you can then
modify the clustering
algorithm to suit
your own needs.
PAUL SAXMAN: And not only can
you actually pull the code out
and modify it for
your own needs.
But then you can
also contribute
it back to the project.
We do have some guidelines I
think for contributing back to
the project.
MANO MARKS: Right.
PAUL SAXMAN: I think probably
code styling.
But yeah, if you have any ideas
or code, I think it
would be a great thing for
us in the community.
MANO MARKS: It's all hosted on
Google Code, code.google.com.
And we will provide a
link to that in the
description of the video.
And it's also linked off the
documentation under More
Resources for the
JavaScripts API.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, and I
personally never remember.
So I always just
search for it.
MANO MARKS: Yeah, if you search
for Google Maps API,
you totally get library
[INAUDIBLE].
You'll find it.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yep,
so first hit.
I just searched on Google
Maps utility library.
It's actually in Google
code hosting.
So the source repository
I think is
subversion if I'm not mistaken.
Yeah.
MANO MARKS: That's right.
And if you click on the
wiki, it actually
has pages that describe.
So there's one for libraries
that gives you the quick link
to each of the libraries
that are there.
We're not going to
have time to go
through each of the libraries.
But we're going to concentrate
on some that are specific to
markers and the ones that we
feel are the most broadly
applicable to what
you guys need.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, and if we
were to take a look at the
screen here-- so the Google
Maps utility library V3.
The V3 is because it's for the
JS library version three.
Lots of stuff in here
like Mano said--
I mean, Key, Drag, Zoom, Info
Box, MarkerClusterer.
Actually you're going
to talk about
MarkerClustererPlus, I think.
MANO MARKS: No, I'm just going
to talk to the basic
MarkerClusterer.
But MarkerClustererPlus simply
adds a few additional options,
which I won't get to.
PAUL SAXMAN: Cool, and I'm
going to talk about the
StyledMarker and RichMarker.
Because they're two ways you can
pretty easily get to kind
of nice effects or nice styles
for your markers besides just
the kind of standard push pin.
And I definitely recommend if
you haven't used the utility
library, just kind of come
here or check out
the wiki on the front.
And kind of browse through and
see some of the others.
Not all these were
developed by us.
So as I said, this is an
open source project.
A lot of these are submitted
by the community members.
So try to provide attribution
for those.
Because I think the first one
I'm going to start out with is
StyledMarker That was actually
contributed by--
if we go back to the code--
Gabriel Schneider.
It looks like Gabriel committed
this around 2010.
And so the StyledMarker library
is actually a really,
really simple way to get custom
marker styles in the
form of either markers, your
classic markers, which is the
kind of the inverted tear
drop or bubbles.
And the way the library does
this is it actually uses
another Google API, the
Charts API, to render
these on the screen.
So you can see here if we go
back to the screen, I have
five different types
of markers on here.
And these all use the library
for generating these.
So this is just a form of a
bubble with some custom text.
These are actually just
variations of
the standard marker.
A nice thing about this
library-- can provide your own
text, not only the bubble but
also into the markers.
And I believe with the markers
themselves, you can actually
provide up to two characters.
So if you have a lot of data and
you want to go from A to Z
back to AA to AB, something
like that, you can do it.
Or for example--
MANO MARKS: Haxcode
your markers.
PAUL SAXMAN: There we
go, even better.
Another thing you can do-- you
can obviously just get rid of
all the information and just
do the standard marker.
And there's a little
feature in there.
You can actually add this little
star, which is kind of
cute I think, a nice way to
kind of highlight some
information.
Another interesting thing
about this too is that--
so the style of marker
class in JavaScript--
it actually inherits from
the marker class.
So things like dragability,
flat, whether or not you want
to render a shadow or not,
that's all built in.
You just modify those parameters
the exact same way
you would if you were dealing
with a standard marker.
So this is really kind of
like a marker plus.
And I'll show you real quick how
that looks like in code.
So you can see what I've done
is that you have to actually
download and import
this library.
An alternative to that is that
you probably link to it
directly from our code site.
So just rely on the fact that
that code is there.
The only question about that
would be as if you're linking
directly from code site if the
library changes in some way.
Or if you want to modify the
library, you're probably going
to want to keep a local copy.
But kind of as I said before,
if we take a look here-- so
the style marker.
You're actually creating these
the exact same way
you create a marker.
You're passing in a
position in a map.
You can also pass in the
additional information like
dragability or whether or not
you want a shadow rendered, or
if you want to change
the anchoring.
Well the difference with the
style of marker is you're
passing in a style icon.
The style icon is
just actually a
pretty simple class.
It takes a type of marker.
So this is either going to
be a bubble or a marker.
So by marker I mean the
inverted tear drop.
And the bubble is actually kind
of the comic style, kind
of a thought bubble.
And then you actually provide
some style properties.
And there's, I believe, in the
bubble there's I think just
three different style
properties.
You can either do the color,
the text, and the star.
And then other way around.
I'm sorry.
So with the marker, you can
do color text and star.
But with the bubble, you
do the color and text.
And you can also change the, I
think, it's the property is
for-- and I might have an
example of that in here--
for actually changing the
foreground color.
So you can actually change the
coloring of the text as well.
I believe that works with both
the bubble and the marker.
So you create the style icon.
You create your marker.
And you passive a style icon.
Another nice thing about the
style marker is that these
styles you can actually
change dynamically.
So if I take a look, I actually
put one of these in
the global context or the global
scope so that I can
actually go back to my
developer tools.
And let's go here, open
up my developer
tools, and find my console.
Oh yeah, I put it down
to the bottom.
Go to my console.
Can we blow this up?
Yeah.
And so here I'm accessing
the style icon.
And I can do things like--
actually let's do this
the other way around.
I can look at my properties.
I can do things like
change the color--
and equals, I believe it's--
actually not so setting
property.
So I'm going to do
this actually.
Let's go back to my
code real quick.
So I style icon--
what property do I want to do?
Actually probably a better way
around if I were to do this,
maybe just take my
marker class.
And I can actually just apply
the style itself, so create a
new style icon.
But since these are--
I wonder if I go back to this
and just reload it, get my
marker in the global context.
And then save that,
reload my page.
I can go back to my marker now
and marker one, and do things
like set options, like I said
before, change things like
dragability if I get
this correct.
And now you can see
things like these
markers are now dragable.
So that's kind of the example
I had down here.
So things like the flatness--
so you see this doesn't
have a shadow.
This one's also dragable.
So these style properties that
are actually dynamically
changeable.
So not only the marker
properties, but also the style
properties.
Maybe I can do a demonstration
of that at another time.
So an interesting thing about
StyledMarker that I mentioned
before that it uses the image
API, the image chart API that
Google provides.
And the way that API works is
actually rendering these
markers actually on
the server side.
So you pass the properties.
You get the image back.
And then you can actually render
that in your website.
Unfortunately that API has
been announced for
deprecation, which
is bad news.
But the good news is it's going
to be around for at
least another two
and 1/2 years.
So I think it's sometime in
April, 2015 or something to
that effect.
So another caveat with this API
is that it's likely safe
to use for at least the
next couple of years.
But if you're building something
for a partner or
consulting and building it for
another company, you probably
don't want to use this API just
to be on the safe side.
Because you probably don't want
them calling you up in a
couple of years saying that
their markers no longer are
rendering properly.
The interesting thing though
is that I'm guessing since
this is actually built on top
of the marker class that it
might just default back to the
original markers if it can't
get an image.
I haven't tested that out.
But definitely for like short
term projects, this is a
really easy way to get markers
on your map, a really quick
and easy way.
The alternative though
is the RichMarker.
So RichMarker is very similar in
that the interface is a lot
like the marker class, but
allows you to actually pass an
HTML code for rendering
your marker.
And it also supports all the
standard marker properties--
things like dragability and
flatness for setting the
shadow and anchor as well.
So you actually change
where it's rendered.
And also like markers or
overlays in general is that
you can also set different maps
or take it out of the
maps, change its visibility
and that type of thing.
So here's an example, if we
go back to the screen.
So this is an example
of a rich marker.
You can see this is actually
a really nice
piece of HTML code.
It has some text in here.
It has an image actually.
You can see if you look
around the edge, it
actually has the shadowing.
That's because it is not flat.
It's actually hovering
above the image.
This one I actually have
dragability on.
So you can see, I can
move it around.
But if we go over here, I
actually created this little
widget over here that lets me
actually change some of the
properties dynamically.
So for example, if I just click
that dragability toggle
there, dragabiity-- you
can now see that this
marker isn't dragable.
I'm doing that just by
setting the options
on the class itself.
You can do things like flat.
If I do flatness, you see the
background disappears.
And visibility we can talk about
as well pretty easily.
So the really interesting thing
about this though is
that this has this concept
of HTML content.
So you give it some HTML code
that you want it to render
inside of the marker.
So here we have some
simplified--
it just says hello.
And it has a background
of green.
If I set that content on the
object, you can see the style
of my marker changes
dramatically.
And I could still go back
and change the other
properties as well.
So we go back to the code.
This one--
the interface is a little bit
different from marker class.
Because it's actually
implementing the overlay.
Is that again the
overlay view?
But it actually works
very much the same.
So you can see here I'm creating
a rich marker class.
I'm giving it a position
on the map.
I set dragability and
anchor on this one.
And the big difference now is
that I'm passing in content.
And this is the HTML content.
I'm doing things-- so there's
actually a lot of convenient
methods on this class.
You can do things like get
flat and set flat, get
dragable, set dragable.
I don't believe these
exist on Marker.
In general, I think access these
through the options.
So it's a little
bit different.
These are actually kind
of convenient methods.
But they are very handy.
But you can also go back and
actually do the set options on
the class and pass in a content
object or set the
dragability by changing the
options of the marker itself.
So either way--
what I'd say is that if
you want this kind of
interchangeable with the classic
marker, so let's say
you want to create
one of these.
And then later in your code,
you want to be agnostic to
whether or not it's a rich
marker, a standard marker, or
even a styled marker, just
use the options, pass
in different options.
If the class doesn't
support that
option, it's just ignored.
So for example, if I have a
marker class, and I pass in
the content option,
I'm just going to
render a standard marker.
Because that option and the
content will be ignored.
And that's a nice way, for
example, like I said before,
with the styled marker, if the
styled marker goes away at
some point, all you'd have to
do at that point is just go
into the top of your code
and change when you're
instantiating these.
Instead of just instantiating
a styled marker, switch over
to a rich marker.
And then the rest your
code will just work.
Because you're relying on the
standard set options property
or function.
So that's it for the markers,
these two styled markers.
Very handy--
you can do a lot with them.
You can dynamically change
their style, dynamically
change the content.
But in terms of more advanced
stuff, I'm going to hand it
off to Mano.
MANO MARKS: So just one
more point on that--
I think these two libraries,
the RichMarker and the
StyledMarker, just really convey
how extensible the Maps
API is through inheritance
and our MDC objects.
So hopefully we'll be doing
another session
on that fairly soon.
But I just really encourage you
to actually start playing
with that kind of extensibility
within the Maps
API, that you don't need to be
stuck with just the properties
and methods that are defined
by the Maps API itself.
PAUL SAXMAN: Actually if you
do have a chance to look at
the code for the
StyledMarker--
StyledMarker is pretty
straightforward.
Because it's actually just
changing the icon using one of
these icons generated by
the Image Chart API.
But StyledMarker on the other
hand, like I said it uses I
think it's overlay layer.
And that's how you actually
can plot pretty much any
information on top of a map and
have it synchronize with
the movement.
So it's a very powerful
technique for putting
information on a map.
It's just that this library
wraps kind of the-- not
necessarily complexity, but
wraps the concept of the
canvas view with the concept of
the marker, which makes it
very convenient to use.
MANO MARKS: So the next one that
I'm going to discuss is
MarkerManager.
Actually both of the ones I am
going discuss sort of get at a
problem of too many markers
on your map.
Now too many markers on
your map has a couple
of different effects.
One is it slows down
your browser.
That's an issue.
But it's also very cluttering.
So if you have tons of stuff on
your map, it actually can
get hard to navigate to and find
the things that you want
and also get a clear sense of
how many things are in a
particular area.
So MarkerManager handles this in
one way which is it allows
you in a very simple way to show
only a limited number of
markers per zoom level.
And what it does is it breaks
down the view port into grids,
and then randomly distributes
your markers that you've
created into that grid.
So for instance, you'll
see here this is a
random weather map.
This isn't using any actual
data, but just some random
weather data generated
by the JavaScript.
And you'll see that
there are about 20
markers on it right now.
At that this particular
zoom level, that's
how many there are.
As I zoom out, the markers will
actually disappear or
more of them will be created.
And as you can see here, I
think we have about 200
markers here.
So this creates an effect very
much like you'll see in many
maps where you can watch the
actual background of the map,
the map tiles--
you see how the style changes
as you zoom in and zoom out.
And smaller cities will
start to appear.
You can simulate that same
effect using MarkerManager.
PAUL SAXMAN: So as you zoom in,
you're going from global
information to kind of regional
information to local
information.
MANO MARKS: Exactly.
PAUL SAXMAN: And this kind of
manages the complexity of kind
of how much you display.
MANO MARKS: Exactly, right.
So you'll see here there's a
bunch of set up for the map.
But basically you import in
the MarkerManager source.
And all of these libraries have
both a compiled and non
compiled version.
The compiled versions obviously
have better
performance.
And the non compiled versions
have more readability in them.
So in this case, this is just
the sample that's right in the
utility library.
But it's loading
in the script.
And it depends on which
option you've passed
in, compiled or non.
So then what we do is
we set up the map.
We create the map.
And we had a listener for when
the bounds change to set up
the weather markers.
And set up weather markers
creates a bunch of random
markers, but also creates a new
marker manager and puts it
onto the map.
And then every time you add a
marker, you're going to add it
into the MarkerManager.
And then the manager you then
pass in some options.
So you'll see here in these
three lines, you add markers.
I say get weathermarkers20.
And it pulls in three.
So basically what this is saying
is give me an array of
20 markers that will show
up at zoom level three.
And then at zoom level six,
give me an array of 200
markers, and at zoom
level eight, 1,000.
And for those of you who are
relatively new to the Maps
API, the zoom levels--
zoom level zero is
the farthest out.
And each zoom level addition
pulls you closer to the map.
So that's basically
how it works.
It's actually a really
easy one to do.
And then you refresh
the manager.
You have created it.
You would then refresh it to
start displaying the markers.
And then the manager just
takes care of the rest.
The other example which is
used quite a bit more is
called MarkerClusterer.
So you'll see here I actually
took the radar search example
which is in our documentation
that pulls in 200 locations
that have the text best view in
Sydney and places them on
the map with these little
star icons.
And you see I can click here.
And I get the name
of the location.
What this does with
MarkerClusterer is it
automatically clusters them.
I give the markers--
instead of giving them
to the map, I
give them to the clusterer.
And then the clusterer
creates clusters.
So you'll see here, in this
marker I have 14.
If I click on that marker, it
zooms in and breaks apart the
cluster into smaller clusters.
But you'll see here that these
outlying stars that are
farther away from the center of
the cluster will actually
show up on their own.
And as I break them down, you
just get the actual locations.
So this is a good way of
conveying the exact number of
things in an individual area.
And you can see as I zoom
out, it re-clusters.
And it handles changing
the style.
There's automatic ways in which
it changes the style.
And you'll see the numbers
here above 10 are in--
what is that?-- orange,
I guess.
Yes, sorry I have a
little slight red
deficiency in my vision.
So those are orangish.
And then you see as I pull
out even farther, it will
re-clustering.
PAUL SAXMAN: So they're really
capturing density as well
which is nice.
MANO MARKS: Yeah, right.
And so over 100, you
actually get red.
And so what I got was total
of 191 results.
So the code for this
is pretty simple.
Again, what I did here was I
created a markers array, which
is initialized right here.
And then I'm pulling in
the places search.
And when the bounds change, it
actually performs the search.
We've covered there places
before, so I'm not going to go
too much detail in that.
But basically I'm adding an
event that performs a search.
And at the end of the performing
of the search, it
has a call back.
A call back is just
called callback.
And at the end of that, I create
a marker clusterer.
And I assigned it to the map.
And I assigned the array
of markers to it.
So this is the simplest
example.
I'm doing no real
customization of the clusterer.
I'm just saying you handle all
the options here and figure
out how to actually do it.
PAUL SAXMAN: So if we do--
like when you're creating your
marker class there, you're not
specifying the map, right?
MANO MARKS: So that's
the important thing.
When I create an actual marker,
I do not specify a
marker in the process.
So
PAUL SAXMAN: Do I
just say marker?
When you create--
MANO MARKS: You do not
assign the map.
Because if you assign the marker
to the map, then it's
going to display
it on the map.
You assign it to
the clusterer.
And the clusterer figures out
when to assign it to the map.
PAUL SAXMAN: OK, so this is a
little bit different from the
last example we saw with sort of
the MarkerManager in there
where the MarkerManager as
you're zooming in, you're
displaying more information.
This one likewise, we're
Because the markers are
expanding, except that with
the clustering you get things
like the density.
And you also get the information
about the number
of markers that are clustered
within each of these kind of
metamarkers.
MANO MARKS: That's right.
PAUL SAXMAN: So you're
preserving a lot more
information using
this technique.
MANO MARKS: Right.
On the flip side of that, with
MarkerManager, you can sort of
say OK, at this level these are
the ones that you display,
whereas with the
MarkerClusterer, it's
effectively displaying them all,
but within these clusters
instead of at different
zoom levels.
PAUL SAXMAN: And we don't
have examples
of this today, though.
But there's other clustering
techniques as well, like I've
seen things like the spider
web clustering.
MANO MARKS: Right.
PAUL SAXMAN: So the idea of
clustering is pretty powerful.
MANO MARKS: Right.
And heat maps is in an extreme
variation of that.
It's basically giving you
information about density of
objects in an area.
There are some advanced
options.
I'm going to just do a
quick example here.
This is [INAUDIBLE] from the
official utility library.
You can actually set the max
zoom level and which markers
will be clustered.
So if I set it here at seven,
at a certain point if I get
down below seven, it will
just automatically
break up all the clusters.
And I chose a bad
area where there
are actually no clusters.
But if, for instance, I zoom in
here, it'll break them up
fairly quickly.
I can also choose
cluster size.
So you'll see before
this was around--
that's what I didn't do
is refresh the map.
So I can make the clusters
bigger or smaller.
So it will attempt to put them
into clusters around size 80.
And here you see that the
maximum level there.
I can also change the styling.
So change this to default.
So here I can style the icons
with custom icons.
So you can choose your
own icons for
the different styles.
And one thing that people will
do is instead of creating just
one cluster, they may create
several MarkerClusterers if
they want a cluster different
kinds of objects.
So if I wanted to have a people
or a heart as my icon,
you might have a cluster
of people and a
cluster of heart icons.
PAUL SAXMAN: I mean both these
techniques, I think, are very
useful, not only for
visualizations.
Like if you want to the
display density--
I don't know what this is--
but density--
MANO MARKS: Of random things.
PAUL SAXMAN: Random things
on your map.
But also just as a standard
technique first Maps.
Because a lot of people--
let's say if you wanted a
restaurant finder, you
probably don't want to display
a marker for every restaurant
in Europe if the user zoomed
out at a certain level.
So you could use this technique
to kind of let users
kind of drill down.
So it's kind of broadly
applicable I think.
MANO MARKS: Yeah, for instance
you have an auto retail site.
And you want to show where
all your dealerships are.
In large cities, there
may be a lot of them.
But if somebody's looking over
Europe, they want to know
where is the place that I can
go so I can try a bunch of
different dealerships to try and
get the deal that I want
or the specific car
that I want.
And so they'll look for
the cities with the
most markers in them.
PAUL SAXMAN: OK, well with that
I think that's it for our
demos today or for what we're
going to talk about.
I mean it seems like we could
even have a whole talk on
clustering at some point.
MANO MARKS: Right.
PAUL SAXMAN: Because it's a
really powerful tool I think.
MANO MARKS: Well, in
not just this.
But yeah, looking at different
algorithms for clustering and
certain [INAUDIBLE].
If you do searches online for
clustering algorithms, you'll
find a lot of different ways
in which people have
implemented these kind
of clusters.
PAUL SAXMAN: Cool.
All right, so that's it.
If you guys have any questions,
feel free to post
them in the YouTube stream
or on the Google+ post.
And we'll try to get
back to you.
If you have any ideas for shows,
if you really want to
see more marker clustering, let
us know as well, or ideas
for future shows.
And with that, we'll catch
you next week.
MANO MARKS: All right.
Thanks a lot, everyone.